some students passing by the lee pascal  rose garden at unlv received quite the  treat today  members of the department of dance put  on two different socially distant  performances  they tell us one routine was inspired by  greek mythology  while the other a contemporary piece and  they were just  excited to share all of their hard work  with others  to be able to work on the piece that we  are doing for our virtual concert as  well as the stuff we've been working on  in class  to be able to show that to everyone is  so rewarding  and so it for me today it's just been  enjoyable  so nice to see that too she says with  what's going on in the world right now  she wants to live every day to the  fullest and part of that  is sharing the art of dance